Big Ben won't bong in celebration like
the brexit errs want but at 11:00 p.m.
on Friday midnight in Brussels they'll
get their freedom they've long desired
the UK's 47 years of awkward marriage
with Europe will finally end in divorce
the British wanted all the benefits of
European integration without having to
engage in many of the internal
trade-offs necessary for it to work when
France West Germany Belgium Italy
Luxembourg and the Netherlands first
United their coal and steel industries
in 1951 the UK didn't join the new club
it was the EU forerunner created to stop
a war ravaged continent ever fighting
itself again the British attitude was
well this is a great idea you should go
ahead but we don't really need it thanks
because we won the war I think there was
a sense here that a we weren't weak
enough to need that sort of crutch and
that be actually we had the rest of the
world we had the Commonwealth we had the
United States in addition to Europe and
as a leading colonial power with a
global role we didn't want to tie
ourselves to something as regional and
smaller simply Europe by the 60s the
European Economic Community as the six
countries had become looked more
alluring to British eyes it was
economically successful compared to an
increasingly uncompetitive UK but French
president shall de Gaulle played
hard-to-get twice rejecting London's
proposal
it wasn't until 1973 that the UK and
Europe finally tied the knot but the UK
always wanted something of an open
relationship it stayed out of the
passport free Schengen area it didn't
join the common currency the euro and it
paid proportionately less into EU
budgets than other member states none of
these exemptions though calmed growing
euro skepticism on the UK's political
rights supported by a largely anti-eu
press some in the Conservative Party
wanted out of the whole thing
fearing the EU was becoming a federal
super state vicious infighting over
Europe bedeviled Prime Minister's
Margaret Thatcher John Major and David
Cameron it is time for the
British people to have their say Ken
Clark was a minister in all their
governments David advantages chances
seen was quite sure he'd win a
referendum he thought it was rather in a
clever way of stopping the party having
these public rounds on the subject and
that was the start of what's become an
historic crisis and so the whole country
going back to square one starting all
over again trying to decide what its
role in the world is Cameron's remain
campaign lost the 2016 referendum Boris
Johnson's levers won but we're next
strength and independence cheer some
poverty and loneliness lament others
much depends on what future relationship
the UK and Europe will have and what
different paths the to take Rory
challon's al-jazeera London